How do I express myself so freely? How
do I take all these po dance pieces I've
been writing and be able to channel all
of that emotion without feeling
self-conscious and be able to bring all
that emotion to the four? That was the
question that I was asked by a Patreon
supporter a couple months ago. And in
this video, I'm going to do my best to
answer it.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, we're going to
talk a little bit about emotional
expression and how one can get there.
But before we dive in, I just want to
give a quick shout out to the friends of
the channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk,
Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Parot
Light Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to
make the videos on this channel
possible. You can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video.
And special thanks to the non-B business
friend of the channel, Pekka Becklanin.
Thank you so very much for supporting my
channel, my work, and my mission. So,
the backstory if you're just tuning in,
uh, I got a piece of feedback from a
Patreon supporter a couple months ago,
basically asking me how it is that I'm
able to express myself so freely and not
feel so self-conscious. Um, I broke that
into two pieces. One of which was the
question of how to feel less
self-conscious. And I did that video
last month. I will link to it down in
the description as well as uh up in the
cards, of course. But really, I realized
that this was two separate questions. uh
they're not unrelated, but simply
feeling less self-conscious is not in
and of itself a recipe for becoming more
expressive. So, how exactly do we do
that? And once again, the actual answer
is therapy. I've been in therapy for
several years now and it has helped a
great deal in unlocking those parts of
me. Um, but I can also single out just a
few things that came out of that process
that I can point you all to. So,
spoilers. Some of the things that I'm
going to be pointing you to are going to
feel kind of small and silly, while
others are going to feel rather large
and challenging. But through it all,
what I'm going to hopefully be pointing
you towards is a way to find more
authentic expression for yourself and
ways to be able to unlock and put that
out in the world. So, let's dive in. So,
tip number one is going to be learning
how to identify what you feel. This may
sound like a really trivial matter, but
I know it turned out not to be for me.
Um, I was never actually taught to uh be
able to identify my feelings. When I
first went into therapy, there was
actually a thing that we do in a
semi-regular basis where my therapist
would ask me how I felt about something
and I would admit, I have no idea. And
so, she would then ask, "Okay, where do
you feel it in your body?" Like, do you
feel a pit in your stomach? Do you feel
a tightness in your shoulders? where
exactly does this live? And by
identifying those kind of physical
byproducts of it, we could then kind of
work backwards and figure out what the
emotion was. It can also be helpful to
say like look at a wheel of emotions and
uh kind of narrow down based upon the
overarching ones where the more specific
one that you're experiencing is. And
this takes a little bit of time. Like um
you'll be able to identify some some
bigger emotions pretty quickly and early
on, but some more specific ones are
going to take a little while. And I
don't know about you, but to me, I as I
was going through this process, I knew
that I was making progress when I could
point to the emotion and I instantly
felt a weight come off my shoulders. Um
so it takes a little bit of time, but
it's really worth it. And quite frankly,
if you're going to express yourself, you
need to know what exactly it is you're
expressing. Tip number two, this is a
lot more fun and a lot easier. And it's
to make a list of things that you enjoy,
things that bring you joy. And sometimes
these can be bigger things like say, you
know, if you really enjoy travel or you
know, you really enjoy something that
happens like once a year that you get to
experience. Or these can be small things
like for instance uh things that exist
on my list of things that I enjoy uh are
things like there's a little figurine of
a dinosaur called a donicus that I
picked up last year when I was visiting
the uh uh the natural history museum in
New Haven that I adore so much that it
now lives permanently on my desk so I
can go over and look at it and give
myself just a little bit of joy when I'm
working uh or for example uh winning a
connections puzzle by uh solving it in
reverse rainbow order. Uh that always
brings me a kick of joy. Whether big or
small, the things that bring you joy are
important because they're things that
you can use as a pickme up or things
that uh you can kind of engage with when
you're having a difficult day rather
than kind of sitting in those
difficulties. And again, this is going
to become a really, really important
factor in being able to open up your
emotional expression by finding what
your joy is. Tip number three, seek out
things that inspire you. Um, whether it
be music, movies, uh, architecture, art,
etc. Take note of the things that really
get your creative gears turning and seek
those things out when you can. You know,
I live in Washington DC, so I've got
kind of an abundance of riches in this
regard. A lot of time, you know, I'll
just hop on the metro and go down and
check out the National Gallery of Art
because it has some of my favorite Monae
and uh Ang paintings and those will give
me a great creative charge. Oh, and
recently uh there's a British painter by
the name of uh Turner who has really
been igniting my creative gears. So find
things like that that really like
stimulate you creatively and it will
help you be able to create things
yourself. And tip number four, which is
kind of an interesting mirror image or
maybe the flip side of the coin to tip
number three, and that is interrogate
your tastes. Figure out what you like
about the things that you like and why.
What is it specifically that jumps out
to you about them? What is it that keeps
you coming back? And also too, when you
dislike something, ask yourself, why is
that? Why does this produce this
reaction in me? What would have to
change about the elements of it for me
to enjoy it? This is kind of developing
an inner critic in some ways, but I
don't think it's an inner critic in a
destructive way. I think it's a way of
identifying what your tastes are so you
can produce your own work around them.
And again, if our goal is authentic
expression, it's an important way to get
there. And tip number five, now I'm
going to drop one of the really, really
hard ones on you, and that is to learn
self-love.
Uh, I know that that is a very very
general thing to say and you know,
believe me, there's a lot that goes into
that and I could probably make an entire
video on it in and of itself, but
fundamentally, if you're going to
express yourself, you have to think that
you have something that is worth saying.
You have to have something inside of
yourself that you identify as beautiful
and worthy of being out there in the
world. And so, you need to go through
the process of learning to value that.
You need to go through the process of
recognizing what your flaws are and
learning to love yourself despite that.
You need to go through the process of
recognizing that you don't have to be
the fastest, the smartest, the most
talented to be worthy of creating
things. You learn to love yourself just
as you are. And that makes it a lot
easier to be able to put things out into
the world that are a byproduct of that
internal beauty that you're now seeing.
And yes, that is a process. It takes
years. It's very difficult. I'm still
working on it. But it also becomes the
cornerstone of being able to produce
things that you're both proud of as well
as bring something from inside of you
out into the world around you. And now
we have a special bonus round because as
I was outlining this video, I realized I
had a little bit more to say that didn't
really fit under any of the bullet
points that I already outlined. So, here
goes. And this is going to sound a
little preachy and a little judgy, but
stick with me here. And that is to train
yourself to seek beauty instead of
clout. Now, as I'm saying that, of
course, everybody says they're not
seeking clout, but you know what? A lot
of us are. whether we want to admit it
to ourselves or not. And this goes into
the self-love thing. There there's a
moment where you can look at yourself
and say, "Yes, I want attention." And
that's okay. It's not bad to want
attention. Lots of people want
attention. That's a normal human thing
to do. But it's also important to
recognize the moments when we are
compromising our authentic expression to
seek that clout and to make peace with
ourselves and the fact that when we do
produce something that is authentic,
more than likely it's going to be met
with some really defensive reactions.
When you express yourself authentically,
this becomes very very challenging to
people who are perhaps not in that same
space themselves. It reveals the ways
that they are being fake, it reveals the
ways in which they fear the judgments of
others. And rather than kind of
interrogating that and dealing with that
on its own terms, they're more likely to
project that shame on to you. And so
it'll come in the form of, you know, uh,
kind of snarky comments. It may come in
the form of insults. Uh, people will
tell you what you're doing is bad in
various different ways. Ask me how I
know.
And you kind of have to make your peace
with the fact that that is going to
happen. It is kind of an unavoidable
side effect of creating something that
is authentic to yourself because by
definition it is something that is true
to you and thus kind of unique. And so
it's going to exist outside of the world
that a lot of people are comfortable
with. And it sucks. There's no doubt
about it. That is not something that is
a happy thing to accept, but it's also
out of our control. You have to believe
that there is more value in producing
something that you personally think is
beautiful than there is in being liked.
That's tough. I'm still working on that.
But it is what I think is kind of the
final piece of the puzzle. When you are
expressing yourself authentically, you
are also doing so from a place where
you're just happy that the thing exists
in the world. And it doesn't matter
whether it gets a big reaction from the
world or not. If getting a big reaction
from the world is what you're looking
for, then expressing yourself
unfortunately is not the way to do it.
So that is what I have to say on the
matter. Thank you all so much for tuning
in and thank you to the Patreon
supporter that inspired this video and
the other one in the first place. Again,
I will link to that other video down in
the description. Um, what did you think
of this list? Uh, do you have thoughts
based upon my thoughts? Were there
things that you think are helpful for uh
creating authentic self-expression that
I didn't mention that you think should
have? Uh, please leave me a comment and
let me know. Be sure to like, share,
comment, and subscribe to help other
people find this video. and of course to
help my channel
grow. This video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on
Patreon. In particular, I'd love to give
a shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now. Thank you
all so much for your very generous
support. And if you out there want to
support the channel and you're not
currently supporters, here are three
ways that you could do it. Number one,
if you want to get your name in the
credits or access to a host of other
awesome rewards, you can sign up for my
Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo. I'll include a
link to that down in the description as
well as up in the cards. Also, if you
would just like to do a one-off
donation, you can uh hit me up via
PayPal or Venmo. I am Drexfactor on both
platforms. Please and thank you in
advance. And hey, it being mental health
awareness month, if you want to see more
videos that I have done about various
topics in mental health, I will go ahead
and link to a playlist of them, both on
screen as well as down in the
description. Thanks so much for
watching. Have yourselves a very happy
Memorial Day if you live in the United
States, and I will catch up with you
with a new video soon. Peace.